Jeff Karson from Zion bomb good to be
that light heavyweight champion EVSE
thank you very much for coming upon Ryan
Mac what's up thank you very much coming
on yeah Chris I already shook your head
I was gonna sit over here the Ultimate
Fighting Championship finally has a
video game another video game and I was
kind of hopeful about this one yeah I
played some last night huh it's kind of
okay maybe it's not as good as I was
hoping the more I played of it the less
I like really yeah that's annoying yeah
it's made from the guys who made fight
night champion which is a really really
good boxing game yeah but a lot of very
good mixed martial arts game so you know
having those guys make this may be kind
of a weird move especially when EA made
an MMA game out of like I think Tiburon
made that one and that had some really
ambitious weird interesting ideas yeah
and they would have like the devs or
whoever they could get to like talk over
of course you know wasn't Joe Rogan
Goldberg but it was what those things
were like you know with them not having
the license it seemed like it maybe that
forced them to try some things they
wouldn't have tried normal yeah and then
you look at UFC eight and it's kind of
verified bears out where you're like oh
now they have the license they're just
like here's a career mode that is like
totally slapped yeah I'm not mad on the
career mode of the ground games kind of
week yeah let's hop right into it I want
to say I wanted I made a character
yesterday okay it's Chuck Morris
I couldn't make Chuck Norris because why
not because they wouldn't let you have
the the surname because Bruce Buffer
here has to say
somebody just Norris wasn't in the list
it wasn't more it wasn't like they were
specifically blocking the truck Norris
okay but with a zero and it would've
been fine for those who don't know the
famous fight between a Chuck Norris I'm
not sure hope we can cost to Enter the
Dragon this Chuck Morris does not look
like Chuck Norris do we see the real
Chuck Norris oh we can see that's as
close as I got we're hearing it to the
dragon I need to hear it I mean I guess
like it you know like he's not wearing
the ghee yeah she's named Colt I had it
I had white shorts
that's his clothes they don't have white
pants no didn't I put them on BJJ shorts
or something I don't know yeah it's
pretty restrictive which is a pain
because the Fighting champion stuff
allowed you to like share fighters and
stuff right but apparently they were
really scared of a copyright
infringement this time around because
you could just straight up have rocky
and Gollum and gang
right sure but they're not necessarily
scared of the copyright stuff I bet they
just didn't build it because my first
game right and they need something for
next year or didn't have time to do it
until next year because yeah this game
just feels stripped down bare bones the
career mode just there's not a lot to it
except for like these 8 second video
clips of Dana White going good fight you
did it good going that are just super
lame also if you try and share those on
the PlayStation 4 it's straight up just
couple stories every video is well
apparently when you stream it it even
like cuts the commentary yeah which my
music
what yeah the background music cuz I'd
Linkin Park playing for Chuck Morris you
know obviously of course American Hero
yeah Americans love licking Park yeah
you guys have the rights for that
yeah just won't let you is super weird
yeah oh I do like they animated Bruce
Buffer holding the microphone yeah dudes
are evil Avene yeah they gettin got the
referees in here I missed the original
dude like that's when I think about UFC
I think about John was a big John card
yeah like he is the UFC ref of record
even even if he has not worked for them
for years
alright so who is Chuck Mars that'd be
Jeff you know oh I'm good playing then
okay are you playing I thought I was
playing I mean we can do change sides
you just said the select sides is
confirmed so Ryan okay so now you're
Chuck Mars now yes and Jeff is Bruce Lee
if I'm gonna get trophies though okay
there goes half our viewing audience
they're just in it for the trophy
side control look at this I'm gonna do
want to get up Oh Bruce if you've
offended a dragon all you have to do is
Bruce Lee is just grab a clump of chalk
mark his chest hair whatever I'm gonna
break his damn neck and then and then
the cat will look at you you'd be cat
one of the things I found playing this
last night is that punches don't really
feel like that that's strong you know I
feel like there's yeah I'm in there
that's staggered I'm there Oh Chuck
Morris you were hitting on her it's for
yeah it's like l2 and what were yeah
that's like the Houthis trying to get it
I was that was that was the that was not
the main event you needed to be like
water
I need you'd be like I couldn't do it
yeah Chuck Morris is more like bored
that's the sick replay here so this is
closer you get to the creating him
because the the hair that's yeah finding
okay it's really dated there's no
sliders I think if you want it's like if
you want this fight in a video game
though you got a go play Street Fighter
Alpha that chun-li stage that is
basically the the stage from returning
the dragon like that's that's just a
much better a much better feeling
representation